next question Republicans and I thought
this was an amazing part of this
documentary and so [ __ ] cool and like
part of me really admires Jordan for
having the balls to do this yeah break
this part down okay so he the the line
about Republicans buy sneakers to that
we've all heard about Michael Jordan
right comes from a North Carolina
election where a guy was running for
governor yes I believe his name is Helms
and he was running against this guy
named Gant Helms was like this [ __ ]
racist white guy who was running for his
fourth term and Gant was a black guy
right coming up I guess that would been
his first you know time as governor etc
and Gant I guess asked for Jordans
endorsement to do like a commercial
yeah and Jordan said on a bus or like on
the plane like with a bunch of other
players there he was Republicans about
sneakers - yeah right these two episodes
are really interesting because you get
into Jordans business mind a little bit
yeah there was the whole like Reebok
thing yeah so like Reebok had sponsored
the Olympic jerseys and there's a big
Reebok logo on the Jersey and Jordan
didn't want to wear it because they
haven't got warm-ups where you get the
gold medal has a big Reebok logo over
the chest and if you watch the gold
medal celebration well they told him if
the Reebok tried to say if you don't
wear this jacket Jordan in unworthily if
you don't wear this jacket you don't
accept the medal you don't accept the
medal and then there's a clip of Jordan
in the car saying this is the guy
whatever the guys name is he's a
[ __ ] they thinking they're gonna
break me now I got some [ __ ] for they
ass I said I got something for these
[ __ ] so and then go ahead at
the at the medal ceremony if you look at
Jordan in the medal ceremony he's
wearing the jacket cuz all he said is
you have to wear the jacket and draped
over that jacket is a massive American
flag that just happens to be and how do
you hate on that you can't tell him not
to have the American flag on him and we
know what he's doing with the flag but
the public doesn't really know yeah he's
kind of using the flag as you will but
it's fire and it goes into Jordan's
brain like Jordan is out here maximum
like alpha-alpha competitor and he's
gonna get what he wants by any means
necessary um and he looked at that I'm
sure as some kind of competition you
think
you tell you a new [ __ ] OB me wait
why'd I get into that election
oh yes the election so uh apparently he
goes they asked him for the endorsement
and he goes listen I don't and I'm
paraphrasing her he's like I don't know
anything about that I'm not gonna speak
on something I don't know about right I
don't know what the guy stands for I
don't know his politics etc so I could
but I will make a contribution to his
campaign and he makes a contribution to
his campaign his being the black I can't
yet which is left out of the story which
I [ __ ] like and he goes I never
looked at myself as an activist yeah I
looked at myself as a basketball player
and that was my singular focus and the
way that I make changes by example it is
it is really really interesting because
there's always this pressure on black
people in Barack Obama summons that a
perfect summarizes it perfectly on the
show right
he goes did that black people are looked
at as great crossover stars as long as
they don't get too political right as
long as they don't ruffle too many
feathers etc they're universally
accepted and the second you get into
politics and start becoming an activist
then you could separate everybody in San
Francisco loves Colin Kaepernick even
when he's not playing great until all of
a sudden he starts taking a knee and
that's who the [ __ ] is this guy he can't
play ball this out the other I thought
it was incredibly brave of Michael
Jordan to do that you know what's gonna
come with it you know the cost of it
and I know there's lot of people listen
right now is like you have a
responsibility to stand up for your race
to stand up for these things and I agree
with you I completely agree with you
I'll never be able to understand it as I
stand here as like a white guy and I'm
coming from a majority where I don't
need to every second I get represent
whiteness that being said does he have a
greater impact as Michael Jordan the
superstar and Michael Jordan the
activist I think so are there any
activist in his era I'm not talking
Martin Luther King that's where i'ma
Malcolm X I'm talking about in Michael
Jordan era and afterwards or there any
activists that have had the global
impact Michael Jordan is hat you could
argue Muhammad Ali and that's that's the
guy Sarah though in the eighties know
I don't know who was really political in
the 80s I don't know what I mean my
brother Jesse Jackson I mean there's
time like a flee like celebrity wise
there wasn't it wasn't a time I'm not
talking about celebs I'm talking about
any activist politicians that are what
Jackson I guess
did he create as much change I don't
know nobody created change that Jordan
created so at the end of the day if the
goal is create change and he goes about
it by not being political and
potentially alienating half the country
if he simply just goes about but I'm
gonna go show by example what I can do
it's like you don't think that there was
a few kids of racists that grew up
idolizing Michael Jordan and had a
really hard time hating black people
because their [ __ ] hero their God was
this black guy I would argue you could
do you could find it in Jordan again as
a brilliant guy he could find the way to
be like you know this guy's just
whatever we just can't stand for racism
this guy set some racist it's a little
weird though because Jordan has the
reputation of not being on really the
side of the people he's always just been
like hey all I care about is making
money and I thought he's always stayed
out of politics has never really donated
never really try it never gives back
that much he doesn't want to alienate
people by by speaking yeah you'll donate
money behind the scene and that's why
the black community kind of like looked
down I'm like yo you can bring about so
much change with your power and you
refuse to do it because I don't want to
Andrews argument is and this may be
Jordans - I don't I make the most change
by not alienating people with opinions
that could alienate them I'm going to
play basketball at the highest level
supreme supreme athlete the greatest
ever quite possibly and then you will
worship me and then you will probably
hopefully rethink some of your views
hopefully I got a I got a comic friend
and I won't say his name but he happens
to be Mormon right a devout Mormon he's
[ __ ] hilarious right I will only
reason I might say his name because I
don't want I don't know if he would want
me to say this but like right but he
never speaks about being Mormon he just
goes out there and tells [ __ ]
hilarious joke clean hilarious clean and
hilarious jokes and I asked him I was
like why don't you ever talk about that
you could be the biggest Mormon guy ever
like they would come out for you and
like this would be he goes I do more for
the community by not talking
hmm I go what do you mean he goes i
normalize it when people just come out
and see me and they don't feel like it
has to be a Mormon thing it's just hey
I'm going to see a comic the next time
you see a Mormon person you're not gonna
look at them like some weird cult
you're not gonna say oh that's oh
there's a Mormon what's a Mormon that's
that I've never been a Mormon I'll do it
oh yeah I think he's Mormon that's the
idea yeah that's it and look whether it
works or not who knows but it is one way
of going about it and we'll never know
if Michael Jordan was politically
activated if he would have created more
change because we can't go back yeah but
it is undeniable that he has created
change and has created I mean he was the
most beloved figure figure in the world
a black American man the most beloved
figure in the world yeah there has to be
a certain amount of progress attached to
that for sure
sure I'm sure it's attached to it but
it's still without him doing anything so
it's like it's just the fact that he was
such a great player and people idolize
him so what does it hue actually do I
don't know one way or the other and I
don't think we can know to Andrews point
his whole thing when he even talked
about the marketing of his sneakers
essentially he goes all I wanted to
focus on as being the greatest player
ever
that was the marketing for my sneakers
so I could if they've been that sneakers
that's directly his bottom line is a
main source of income yeah so you could
also argue his logic would be if I want
to make any change so societally the
best thing I can do is focus on my craft
and that will bleed into everything else
he was singularly focused on his craft
and that fed everything else and he says
that exact line now the one thing I
thought was interesting because I do
look at it like you could have said
something but one thing that no I
noticed was the only one who seemed to
have like an understanding of what he
was going through his Barack Barack
Barack gave him some sympathy and he
said something like Michael was still
figuring out who he was as a man or
something like that and that's a lot to
figure out at such a young age Barack is
the only per our three people on earth
who would understand what Michael Jordan
is going through was going through at
that time it's Barack
it's Michael Jordan is maybe Oprah and
low-key Barack
and I don't know enough about Oprah to
say but like Barack
I'm sure black people the second he got
in office want him to get an office and
be a guy first thing we're doing
everybody gets the forty acres in annual
we want a man like we didn't get I mean
I Patrice had that funny joke about
everybody gets a white son and the white
slave I don't mean like and now if what
he also knew but he also knew he
couldn't do that because the biggest
fear of all those white people that
weren't gonna vote for him was the
second he gets an office everybody's
getting the white slave yeah so he
understood that responsibility and I
would say by him being black and being
president United States of America that
alone even if he does nothing else that
alone has such an impact on little kids
growing up realizing that they could
reach the highest all you know level of
our entire world if they want to like
that itself showing these often times
better than telling because telling what
we agree and it's sweet and it's
nourishing you know what I mean it's
like you go to a church service or any
of these things I've been to plenty of
the churches and I feel great when I
walk out and right it's like candy it's
like you're chewing it I'm feel positive
I want to hug people everything's great
and then a few hours later you like okay
it goes away maybe the next day you
forgot all about it and showing doesn't
go away telling goes away showing is
always there I can't be President I'd
say that guy was why can't you well is
dividend that guy was
[Applause]